[Music]
Betty together on the set of Valley Girl
it's a fact and I you were joking with
me that day oh I know what you say about
how much you love Chloe Chloe's don't
you know well I mean you were telling me
you wanted to date her but she was taken
you were telling me you thought she was
the perfect person and now you seem to
be dating right here's the thing about
Chloe she's dug mrs. doe I talked to
your brother earlier he told me he's got
to move out of his house he's got to
find a new place to live we're working
on moving out so yeah that's the only
way to fix the problem because the Jake
ballers are just always outside no
because I also have to find a new place
to live yeah I'm getting kicked out but
it's it's time for me to move into a
house I'm adulting is anything gonna
change about your new situation I can't
say because I feel like people will just
prank my house but it will be bigger
more savage and more member last
question for you you have so many rabid
fans what's the craziest fan encounter
you've ever had I had a girl caressing
my face she crushed my face in most
right
other